das war also die letzte
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit angela
merkel sie wird sie vielleicht nicht
wirklich vermissen sie hat gesagt es war
teil ihres politischen lebens und wir
wissen peter tiede was der letzte satz
war den sie hinter verschlossenen türen
bevor alle auf das podium gegangen sind
gesagt hat sie hat gesagt jetzt an siege
wünscht alles gute und schlauer
entscheidung ab der nächsten woche das
war quasi ihre hinterlassenschaft für
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an die
länder und an olaf scholz ihren
nachfolger welche rolle hat sie denn
sonst eingenommen oder beziehungsweise
wie muss man sich jetzt die veränderung
ohne angela merkel da am
ministerpräsidenten tisch wenn es dann
noch mal so eine konferenz gibt
vorstellen also angela merkel hat
natürlich ganz ganz viel auf sich
gezogen und ganz viel von gewitterwolken
die eigentlich über die
ministerpräsidenten hätten schweben
müssen und auch halten niederregnen
müssen auch sie selbst gezwungen indem
sie es zugelassen hat und als auch
organisiert hat dass entscheidungen die
die länder eigentlich hätten alleine
treffen können mit ihr zusammen
getroffen wurden und dadurch hat sie
sich halt selber auch zur hauptfigur in
der in der korona krise gemacht sie
hätte es nicht machen müssen da werden
auch die länder da gewesen die länder
haben die kompetenzen gesundheitsschutz
und katastrophenschutz ist in
deutschland ländersache allerdings muss
der bund immer bezahlen also alles was
die länder wollen die können sich immer
nur einigen wenn am ende ein anderer
bezahlt und das ist dann in der regel
oder bunt angela merkel hat dann immer
gezahlt das ist richtig teuer geworden
aber das war auch notwendig und olaf
scholz wird das anders machen olaf
scholz hat ja mit der ampel schon dafür
gesorgt dass ist alles anders wieder an
den bundestag zurück gegeben wird dass
es keine sonderrechte gibt es im prinzip
die abschaffung dieses kroner
zentralkomitees wo zentral aus berlin
mit dem ministerpräsidenten darunter
entschieden werden konnte das ist
abgeschafft und da müssen uns umstellen
jetzt also noch mal ein akt der
nationalen solidarität so hat angela
merkel ihr statement vorhinein geleitet
gehen wir mal kurz noch mal durch was
das bedeutet also zweig
flächendeckend unabhängig von instanzen
also beispielsweise für den einzelhandel
beim einkaufen nennen wir es das was es
ist lockdown für ungeimpfte die können
außer zu edeka aldi lidl netto und
rosbach oder zu ross man dies anders mir
einkaufen gehen das ist vorbei auch
nicht wenn sie getestet sind also nur
geimpfte und genießen sie könnten nicht
mehr zu kultur nicht zur kultur
veranstaltungen gehen sie können nicht
mehr zu fußballspielen gehen dazu
anderen sportveranstaltungen das war
einmal wer nicht geimpft ist der davon
nichts mehr teilnehmen da kann sich nur
noch die grundnahrungsmittel selber
kaufen also weihnachtsgeschenke online
alles andere auch das war's das ist
wirklich wirklich der lok dort für
sportveranstaltungen ist das stichwort
bei bundesligaspielen beispielsweise
15.000 zuschauer maximal dann ein
interessanter punkt finde ich auch ganz
wichtig 30% stadionauslastung oder
maximal 500 allein bei kleineren stadien
kann das dann auch sein oder ist es das
stadion richtig muss über 100.000
christen auch nur maximal 15.000
wichtiger punkte der alle betrifft auch
die private zusammenkünfte und kontakte
dürfen beziehungsweise ab einer 250er
inzidenz werden clubs und diskotheken
geschlossen und ab einer 350er inzidenz
sind private treffen und zusammenkünfte
in innenräumen nur noch für 50 personen
und in außenräumen für 250 personen
möglich auch unter 2 geht es würde
bedeuten wir haben im moment über 400
immer noch das würde bedeuten sobald das
alles sozusagen verabschiedet ist und
dann in kraft tritt hätten wir in der
jetzigen situation private treffen nur
noch 50 personen in private feiern alle
feiern alle veranstaltungen in
innenräumen privat und und andere also
auch von drei tage dürften nicht größer
sein also 50 drin 200 draußen und vor
allem auch zweig also da auch kein um gm
für private zusammenkünfte für private
treffen gilt auch da eine art nicht
geimpften lockdown die dürfen sich nur
noch ein haus stand das kann aber auch
die freundin kann auch die
lebensgefährtin sein die man im
hausstand lebt das ist ein ausstand ein
haushalt plus zwei leute sowie also
irgendwo ein ungeimpfter ist reduziert
sich alles ein haus stand zwei leute
sind alle geimpft oder genießen heißt
dass wir können uns voll treffen bis zu
diesen 50 aber ansonsten heißt das
einfach nur sowie ein geimpfter dabei
ist also ein geimpfter vermiest jede
partie und wir schauen bei den regeln ja
jetzt wieder auf die inzidenz werte und
nicht auf die hospitalisierung since
talent eben auf die auslastung der
krankenhäuser was wir eigentlich ab
jetzt nur noch machen wollt bzw seit
einigen wochen hatte ich das verwundert
ja absolut man reibt sich die augen und
weiß nicht mehr was jetzt gilt plötzlich
ist die instanz wieder so hopplahopp
einfachsten gut geführt wir dachten
diese eingemotteten raus aus der
mottenkiste zu frau merkels abschnitt
kommt die inzidenz nochmal wir wissen
nicht mehr was wir überhaupt noch machen
sollen also jetzt müssen wir doch wieder
auf die auf die inzidenz gucken die
relativ und unsicherer wert ist die
hospitalisierung rate ist auch nicht so
doll wie man gedacht hat man sich
einfach auf die inzidenz nicht mehr
allein berufen kann wenn man sich das
anschaut wir haben eine inzidenz bei
über 400 die ist sehr sehr hoch die
hospitalisierung since ident ist aber im
vergleich zum letzten jahr deutlich
niedriger weil eben die geimpften nicht
so schnell in krankenhäuser kommen
deswegen man sucht sich immer den wert
den man gerade gebrauchen kann ich sagen
eine vertrauens- fördernde maßnahme ist
das nicht wenn man plötzlich wieder auf
den alten wert geht das da geht wirklich
so dass alte ringelpiez mit anfassen
wieder lust immer kommt was neues sagt
daher immer kommt ein anderer wert wir
kennen das aus dem hohlen ja sagen wir
bei allem was berechtigt da beschlossen
sein sind sie mag es gibt immer so ein
paar sachen wo man sich fragte warum
erklärt ist doch einfach man muss es
einfach nur erklären vielleicht gibt es
eine erklärung die wo wir alle nach dann
nachher dastehen und sagen ja es logisch
aber einfach wieder ins ident ist aus
dem hut zu zaubern und zu sagen die
kupfer wir auf einen ganz anderen wert
wieder eine andere spalte andere tabelle
und man verliert langsam den überblick
deswegen noch einmal weihnachtsmärkte
ganz wichtig jetzt in der weihnachtszeit
die weihnachtsmärkte bleiben offen
können offen gelassen werden komme für
die impfte und genesene kein anderer
dafür ein weihnachtsmarkt auch ein test
nützt da nichts mehr weihnachtsmärkte
dürfen bleiben veranstaltungen schon
sagen und halt wirklich ganz rigoros es
gibt kein shopping für ungeimpfte ja
michael müller hat es noch mal ziemlich
drastisch gesagt der noch regierende
bürgermeister von berlin
er hat gesagt die gruppe der ungeimpften
ist deutlich in der minderheit und ist
für die infektionen verantwortlich
das heißt die mehrheit muss sozusagen
unter der gruppe der ungeimpften unter
der minderheit erleiden weil es dann
eben zu schlimmen situationen kommt das
war eine ganz ganz direkte
schuldzuweisung wenn man sich die zahlen
anguckt die geben dass hier und zwar
kommt drei viertel aller infektionen und
aller die auf die intensivstation in den
krankenhäusern landen die infektionen
gehen von ungeimpften aus das sind es
das ist die wahrheit die generation x
unter ungeimpften ist sogar zehnmal
höher als die ja klar der grund warum es
dann auch die impfung gibt irgendwann
muss das daraus dann mal eine konsequenz
geben das dramatische hierbei ist nur
wieder dass man dass die maßnahmen die
jetzt augenschein nicht nötig sind sonst
hätten sich da auch nicht 16
ministerpräsidenten und an die kanzlerin
umfasst kannst oder altkanzler so darauf
geeinigt aber das ist auch herkunft ist
wieder das in den bundesländern zu spät
mit dem impfen angefangen worden ist
dass wir nicht rechtzeitig gewusst haben
es gibt länder die haben rechtzeitig
gebucht hat es gibt bundesländer bei den
funktioniert nicht unterwerfen hinten
und vorne nicht das liegt dann auch
daran
dass die bevölkerung der anders
aufgestellt ist dass die impfskepsis
sind wie zum beispiel in sachsen oder
auch in teilen bayerns oder auch im
thüringer aber es liegt auch daran dass
einige bundesländer schlicht und
ergreifend wieder nicht gekonnt haben 30
millionen booster impfung hat olaf
scholz auch noch mal gesagt nach wie vor
ein ehrgeiziges ziel das sieht er auch
selber so aber sinngemäß man sollte halt
so viel davon schaffen wie es geht
hendrik wüst der neue chef der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz neuer
ministerpräsident in nordrhein westfalen
spricht von einer herausforderung von
einer lage wie seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg nicht mehr in deutschland sind
drastische worte hat er auch noch mal
die bundeskanzlerin zitiert die das auch
schon mal gesagt hat ja es ist es
dramatisch und wie jetzt weiß man auch
warum urlaub scholz sich ein general in
den krisenstab setzt man eine bundeswehr
general motors ist der meinung damit hat
er nicht ganz unrecht dass das jetzt
anders angepackt werden muss werden wir
bis zum jahresende 30 millionen
impfungen brauchen wir echte vom 80 vom
18 november aus dann muss das
generalstabsmäßig geplant werden und das
muss jetzt anders laufen auch da wo es
bisher nicht läuft und dann muss das
wirklich exakt durchgeplant werden und
das kann das kind in deutschland zwei
einrichtungen dass ein dass die
bundeswehr das anders das technische
hilfswerk dann kommen noch ein paar
kommunen mit dazu die das auch content
die das auch hingekriegt habe aber das
muss jetzt generalstabsmäßig gemacht
werden weil wenn das klappen soll bis
zum jahresende und dann reden wir in den
weihnachtsferien wird nicht wie bald
passieren also muss bis weihnachten muss
das durch sein impfstoff scheint genug
dazu sagen ihren spannend heute ein
papier vorgelegt in dieser mpk nach der
genügend impfstoff organisiert werden
kann das hängt auch damit zusammen man
gleich zehn millionen dosen moderner die
eigentlich erst im nächsten jahr
geliefert werden sollen die kommen jetzt
quasi früher dass man quasi schneller
durch ist das früher mehr impfstoff da
ist bei und der geliefert sachen früher
und dann gehen wir verlassen
das ist zum teil den ist natürlich wenn
wenn dann bayern oder einige städte
sagen bei uns kommt nicht genug
impfstoff andern nicht das auch daran
dass sie vor vier wochen zu wenig
bestellt haben so aber das muss jetzt
generalstabsmäßig durchgeplant werden
dafür ist der general da es gibt einen
expertenrat und ich sage mal an dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an diesen
zielen wird sich olaf scholz messen
lassen bis nicks frau merkel